si les plus jeunes ont pu commencer à
reprendre le chemin de l'école cette
semaine ce n'est pas le cas des plus
grands les universités sont fermées
depuis le 16 mars et n'accueillons pas
de nouveau leurs étudiants avant l'été
pour en parler nous en sommes à nous
sommes avec alain buis président de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines bonjour bonjour merci en tout
d'abord d'avoir accepté d'échanger avec
nous pour commencer comment allez vous
écouter on va dire que ça va dans le
contexte actuel personnellement ça va
beaucoup de travail gérer la situation
actuelle mais comme l'ensemble des
personnels de l'université donc avec
vous nous allons revenir sur la façon
dont l'ue fait est ce qu a géré cette
épidémie confinement nous rappelons que
les cours dans l'enseignement supérieur
sont interrompus physiquement commencé à
organiser levesque concernant les cours
la continuité est ce qu'elle a pu être
assurée écoutez c'était une cellule
situation subie comme pour tout le monde
mais il ya un travail remarquable qui a
été fait par deux personnes d'université
vers les équipes pédagogiques en
particulier pour assurer cette
continuité donc là quand unité
administrative qui permet à la trinité
de poursuivre ses activités essentielles
mais également et je voudrais insister
là dessus sur la comptine et pédagogique
c'est à dire d'essayer tout a été mis en
oeuvre dans les conditions difficiles
que l'on connaît mais pour assurer la
poursuite la continuité des
enseignements auprès des étudiants dans
l'ensemble des diplômés des matières et
donc il ya eu un travail remarquable qui
a été fait de la part des les
enseignants des enseignants chercheurs
dans ce cadre là concrètement comment ça
s'est passé ils ont envoyé des cours est
ce qu'il ya pu avoir des cours via
vision que vous fait nous sur ce plateau
écoutez tous les moyens qui existent et
vous savez qu'il y en a beaucoup
paroisse de conférence par des devoirs à
la maison car voilà tous les dispositifs
payet beaucoup d'inventivité les gens su
s'adapter pour utiliser tous les moyens
à disposition et c'est assez varié donc
je ne pourrais pas tous les citer mais
mais il y a eu des cours qui ont été
faits en visioconférence comme on le
voit ici après il ya eu ce qu'on appelle
une forme asynchrone c'est à dire que on
envoie soit par cole et ronnie donc on
envoie des devoirs donc il ya des
échanges de mails et puis on a une
plateforme numérique nous à travers un
système s'appelle google qui permet de
faire des enseignements à distance
c'était pas forcément il n'était pas
encore prêt pour le faire massivement
mais c'est vrai pour toutes les
universités
mais tant bien que mal ça marche et nous
ou et dire que la continuité pédagogique
a été assurée même si évidemment serait
à nouveau un à courre fait en présence
des études concernant les examens c'est
une question qui inquiète beaucoup les
étudiants est ce qu'ils vont être est ce
qu'ils sont maintenus les qui vont être
reporté alors le principe de maintenir
les examens a été a été actée au
maintien les examens mais par contre les
modalités sont variables selon vous
savez où nous sommes univers épuré
dissiper selon les disciplines selon les
les différentes ufr et donc semé tout se
fait sur la première session est sur la
deuxième question se fera à distance
donc ça peut être du contrôle continu ça
peut être des séances d'examen ça peut
être devoir donc vous avez beaucoup de
solutions mais qui ont qui sont adaptés
par rapport aux aux étudiants aux
disciples voudrais parler maintenant des
étudiants en médecine on sait que
certains participent à la lutte contre
l'épidémie
on a parlé son attente sur notre antenne
l'université leur a distribué des
masques et des gants ou mois de mars
comment vous avez soutenu ces étudiants
là alors au delà des étudiants en
médecine qui ont qui ont été évidemment
on joue un rôle important et de manière
générale tous nos personnels on va dire
du de notre composante de santé qui se
sont vraiment pareil de solidarité
beaucoup investi dans dans l'aide pour
la lutte contre le virus et et forêts à
disposition du personnel soignant
l'université a aussi donné tous ces
équipements j'aurai le signaler à
l'ensemble des hôpitaux des ehpad au
moment le plus fort de la crise quand il
ya pénurie de matériel dont je rêvais
rendre hommage ou aux étudiants aux
soignants à nos personnels qui
travaillent dans les hôpitaux ils sont
nombreux on appelle vallée
un public parfois fragile on parle de
précarité d'isolement pour certains
confinement n'a pas pu être toujours
facile lui est ce qu elle met en place
une cellule d'écouté et même eu des
distributions de paniers solidaires et
c'est pareil l'université est amené à
accompagner ces étudiants là alors ça ça
a été vraiment une attention très
particulière de mettre en place tout de
suite des dispositifs d'urgence pour les
étudiants à savoir si une réalité qu' il
ya une part de nos étudiants le fait
qu'on passe à distance il ya un
phénomène de la fracture numérique après
les conditions personnelles parfois ils
sont dans des mondes et logement c'était
universitaire ou ou ailleurs se sentir
isolé ne pas avoir de connexion internet
pour suivre les courses
donc on a mis en place une série tout de
suite de dispositifs d'urgence dead
achats d'achat alors qu'il matériel
informatique de forfaits 4g procédure
aximum et puis il est social
effectivement pour lesquels on soutient
des besoins qui sont liées à l'aide
alimentaire aux produits de première
nécessité et vous l'avez vu il vous
l'avez illustré à travers l'épicerie
solidaire agora et avec le crous et les
producteurs locaux une distribution de
paniers
donc voilà tout ça a été mis en place
pour essayer d'atténuer au maximum les
effets de la crise sanitaire auprès des
étudiants les plus fragiles alors qu'on
a dit pour la suite est-ce que vous vous
préparez une propre potentiel rentrée en
septembre
j'imagine on a beaucoup parlé des
étudiants mais aussi tout personnel
administratif qui doit être en plein
travail pour préparer ça alors déjà il
ya cette étape c'est à dire que depuis
l'annnonce du président de la république
du plan de déconfinement pas partir du
11 mai dont l'université va rouvrir très
très progressivement à partir du 18 mai
en fait l'ac sur les laboratoires de
recherche
vous savez nous avons beaucoup de
laboratoires de recherche qui font des
expériences ont besoin d'être présente
pour faire des expériences alors en
sciences expérimentales et en sciences
du vivant
donc on rouvre mettrait sur un trail des
très faibles effectifs et sur les
laboratoires pour lesquels ils n'ont
plus pu faire d'activités du tout depuis
deux mois ça c'était important qu'ils
puissent reprendre ou
si pour les doctorants ont conçu leurs
thèses dansez dansez dansez discipline
là et donc on réévaluera hausse 8 en
juin jusqu'aux congés d'été mais mais
disons que là pour l'instant la règle
c'est le le travail à distance reste la
règle et le présentiel exception et tout
ça les présents sont animés d'une sur
sanitaire que tout le monde connaît pour
la rentrée c'est un peu plus compliqué
on va la préparer là il faut qu'on
l'anticipé mais on retrouvera pas une
situation telle qu on a connu
l'université avant le 16 mars
donc ce sera probablement une solution
qu'on appelle le terme ces hybridations
entre du distant ciel et du présentiel
enfin pour terminer le projet de fusion
avec lui faire séparer saclay et ce qui
peut être impacté par cette crise
sanitaire
non nous continuons donc verser paris
saclay ça des gens parler de la
continuité des universités il ya encore
environ d'utiliser système de
visioconférence de webconférence tout ça
et peut-être un petit peu ralenti mais
mais en fait on continue de travailler
donc l'université de paris saclay dont
la place de l'ue vs plus donc c'est une
il a cité les choses continuent et
avancent au rythme normal je dirais donc
là dessus je n'ai pas d'inquiétude
particulière
merci à la mairie d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je le rappelle vous êtes
président de l'île verte et
versailles-saint-quentin merci beaucoup